[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
some minor level in the grocery store on
a snowy Christmas Eve I ran into her in
the frozen foods
and I couldn't quite believe
[Music]
recognize the face for the master open
wide
she when she hugged me in the crowds
dispersed
my whole girlfriends now
[Applause]
[Music]
it to tell the whole mentality it's
working wonders in degree
wondered if she had gone all the way
with the body surgery
you
then she climbed into the soup couldn't
look her in the eye
cuz I know about
[Music]
preparing shoe inside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
stage steven crowder
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
they're going ready to have a great
Christmas
awesome how many people here actually
celebrate Christmas okay Hanukkah all
right no accountant looks like it's
turbo tax for you question of the day
for people who are watching live right
now how many people do you know who
actually don't celebrate Christmas it's
far less common than we think the hash
tag by the way right now is a Crowder
Christmas in a promo code for people who
are out there Crowder Christmas you get
$10 off through Christmas right now if
you join mug club as well as $10 going
to a local charity that does that
Christmas baskets for those in need so
let's say here at aura come thank you
yeah thank you so much with wave as well
if you could give them a round of
applause for helping us put this on we
have a lot to get to Santa Claus is here
today
that's always disturbing with a roomful
of 35 year old we don't have a crowd
animator like Bill Maher so you just
have to laugh when I do this and then
want to punch me in the face ah before
we get there all the news that we have
we have Santa Claus my half-asian lawyer
bill Richman is here we have some other
special guests one cheer because someone
needs someone on retainer very nice but
first don't let this be you this
Christmas dinner Liz oh you guys know
who I'm it's is Miz Oh eggy I don't know
but she's not getting up for a while
which one's the Muppet rat is that Rizzo
okay all right now I know I get it - all
right very nice I know you know I'm
looking on the monitor and seeing this
tie I'm really sorry folks I think every
man thinks when they wear tuxedos I can
look like James Bond and said they they
look like their bow tie was tied by a
kid who it was his last make a wish
Merry Christmas you know what you signed
up for we do have some news to get
through though like this California
nativity scene that was in the news if
you hadn't seen this depicting Jesus
Mary and Joseph
as refugees separated in cages yeah the
leap of why did you laughs that is very
creepy sir and it's even creepier can I
by the way give it a run up mrs. Thomas
right here Thomas come up real quick
this was the first man in line tonight
Thomas
okay
get out of here before security shoots
you how well you were like four hours in
advance you got here at four okay so a
lot of spare time on your hands yeah I
imagine you two are doing your own taxes
I appreciate it Thomas I was walking in
and it just shocked the hell out of me
he goes hey and he had a mutt he was out
there very lonely with his mug and you
have it right there and it's empty so
that really just seems like a
bludgeoning tool like Pan's Labyrinth
just gonna break my orbital bone and it
shocks up when you haven't seen Pan's
Labyrinth that's ok Guillermo del Toro
not that great a little overrated the
lead pastor by the way for that nativity
scene if we can bring it back up he said
that he's seen how these asylum seekers
have been treated and quote wanted the
Holy Family to stand in because they
were also refugees very similar - you
know the rapey stuff he didn't say that
that's me editorialize I need to make
sure I don't get accused of figures here
this is the issue with Christmas today
right we don't have that much common
ground anymore I think everyone here is
to have is here to have a good time we
all want to have a laugh but when it
comes to Christmas every single
get-together dinner
family gatherings there's always one guy
who has to politicize it everything I
touch turns into a disaster I guess I
don't know what Christmas is all about
isn't there anyone who knows what
Christmas is all about
short Charlie Brown I can tell you what
Christmas is all about
[Music]
lights please
christmas is just another excuse for
white christian capitalists to shove
their wealth and religion in the faces
of marginalized people it has nothing to
do with the birth of Jesus who wasn't
even born on December 25th your Christ
miss isn't the only holiday Charlie
Brown
what about Hanukkah Kwanzaa where is the
school place to celebrate Yule or the
hallmark movies wishing everyone a merry
winter solstice how about the Diwali
festival of lights you never heard of
the Diwali festival of lights did you
don't get me started on the Salvation
Army all this because America is a quasi
religious anti LGBTQ AIP oligarchy where
Christmas is thrust upon us and everyone
falls for materialism each year like the
good little mindless sheep they are and
they follow their Shepherd Donald Trump
[Music]
that's what Christmas is all about you
sis white male oh brother
good they worked it out yeah those kids
I - kind of a dick yes a little bit I
know that exactly another story is of
course you've been reading about how
many people been following impeachment
at all no no hands down there will be no
mention of that here tonight none it's
Christmas it's a happy place politics
there is no Pelosi here there could be I
have no idea the military is now
investigating an alleged white power
hand gesture do you see this it was
flashed at last weekend's Army Navy game
usually they were talking with white
power gesture the broadcast this comes
to the New York Times the broadcast
showed cadets in the stands making the
common okay or made you look sign that
people like the Southern Poverty Law
Center if you don't know claim is now
racist Southern Poverty Law Center
just don't tell home alone - so that's
kind of yeah was that a snort that's
almost as disturbing as them chewing
Santa Claus at the age of 55 oh the only
thing more disturbing would be if the
median age here was Fox News we cheering
for Santa and self-lubricating pocket
catheters which oh we didn't plan on
talking about I underlined it Kath
attorney one here we used catheters okay
I understand you want a catheter that I
get yeah pocket okay I understand you
wanted but self-lubricating seems to me
that this would not be at the top of my
priority list if I am jamming a glass
rod down my Weiner hole it seems to me I
want to have a little bit more control
over the viscosity a little manual
paka catheters I get self lubricating
that was all it was just gonna side
though really as it relates to mceventyr
Callister was a white white home alone
was a white power advocate though really
we we should have gathered that from
from home alone one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah almost makes you root for Marvin
Harry point they weren't the Wet Bandits
they were simply trying to carry out
justice that's actually pride my
favorite Christmas movie ever home alone
anyone else is that just now it's just
me
thank you two people also like Santa
Claus if you go back and watch there's
no way you can make home alone to
nowadays have you seen like those men
would be dead five times over there's a
scene where Joe Pesci says hey kid
nuttin would trail me more greatly than
to shoot you like oh my god this is
homicide knocking off the Youngs drinkin
I mean all that much to me good Joe
Pesci we're very glad to hear it that's
a horrible for Christmas cheer I think
we can one thing that we're talking with
the white power symbol this has now
become a white power symbol I think we
can all agree that the controversy is
pretty ridiculous now at this point
write a racist behind every corner and
anyone here feel that way I see the one
guy with the Hitler Youth haircut he's
very quiet yeah we're watching him sorry
I hope you're not like sick and you just
had to shave the sides of your head and
I was just very insensitive the guy was
the one who tied the bowtie it was
make-a-wish real racists this is one
thing we've been taught that racism is
secret now everything is a dog whistle
now as we know growing up and we can
just harken back to the old Christmas
specials racists in real life are far
more open about it
[Music]
happy birthday hey I'm alive oh is this
the future if we finally eradicate this
male I don't see any colored children
looks like somebody won the race bull
and you can identify as whatever you
want now who needs a vagina what I
haven't asked I can play with kids ball
but we still need to eliminate white men
and Christians Jews Chinamen and any
other Transpo what say you kids are you
ready to storm into town with me and
slaughter the enemy is that the son of
sleighbells or is that just Susan
Wojcicki immediately eliminating our
channel I'm getting the notification
right now she's just wearing mutt dangly
earrings Ottawa sleigh bells we're all
banned every last one of you speaking of
the Hallmark Channel also another
controversy with Christmas apologized
for pulling ads featuring same-sex
weddings you guys seen this story all
the men here lying that you don't watch
Hallmark Christmas movies of course you
do
it's better than life timers in the life
to it when life time makes you go yeah
it's rough thank God for Hallmark then
it must be really bad the decision this
comes from some news source that I don't
care about decision came after the
company faced calls for the boycott
after pulling the ads for a wedding
planning company in his apology the head
of Hallmark the president promised to be
more inclusive in the future starting
with their new movie a very Folsom
Street Christmas so they're really happy
about that
hey slowly up take the gun
can you bring that back up because I
didn't get to see it I didn't was that
he looks is that no oh there are you it
there he is well you guys put Pete but
gigging that good work run-through is
very late I had no idea what's going to
appear finally in Seattle sorry about
this I'm glad to see no eight-year-olds
in the audience almost seems like Santa
Clauses age-inappropriate at this point
in Seattle a transgender stripper was
hired to entertain a conference on
homelessness because it's 2019 we had a
shortened that Glynn quite a bit that
was it were no longer that was Beyonce
black st. James any fans apparently you
guys don't have her on your Spotify
playlist you don't say black st. James
she danced topless and a sheer bodysuit
gave lap dances kissed attendees this
was a national news story that's right
Beyonce black st. James or she was known
in a former life detective Carl Winslow
so there's that that is so disgraceful
practically a Christmas movie so we
thought we'd shoehorn that in yeah and I
don't feel good about it of course some
people were shocked obviously slightly
uncomfortable others shrugged it off and
they just felt that given the current
climate it's something transgenderism
that's increasingly common in the
workplace it is right before Christmas
and everybody is getting ready for that
big sleigh ride on the night of the 24th
Christmas Eve see all these toys are
made by these
these elves have that certain knack for
time a king all except for this this one
misfit Herbie aren't you finished
painting that debt
there's a pile up a mile behind you
what's eatin you boy well see that's the
problem I guess what I just don't like
being a boy who all is that song what
you don't like being a boy now Hermey
doesn't like being a board honey doesn't
like being a boy Tommy doesn't like
being a boy he doesn't like being a boy
shame on you mind telling me what you do
wanna be well sir someday I'd like to be
a lady Oh Lady well we need one up here
see I've been studying in there's more
Mon blockers and bottom transition
surgery and Phaeton now listen you
you're a boy oh and boy else stay boy
now get to work
[Music]
[Applause]
not for you finish the job or your fire
[Music]
why is he such a trans
I can't stand wearing men's clothes chap
might off with God stuff
and I might fit in gray you could clap
that's okay Wow shucks her selves yeah I
love how Thomas was in the front row
he's like I don't know if I should have
waited nine hours in the freezing cold
today don't worry it's gonna be worth it
this will all pay off eventually that
was it that was actually we had to do
that shot-for-shot recreation there and
that is a horrible film Rudolph the clay
have you gone back and watched that
recently doesn't hold away Santa is
sorry an [ __ ] and that movie's true
he actually walks over we had to do our
research we do a research he walks over
to Blitzen or Donner I believe who was
an apparently Rudolph's father and he
actually and I quote he goes oh you
should be ashamed of yourself daughter
giving birth to a red-nosed reindeer oh
let's not let him join in any reindeer
games as a kid him like that that's his
son borderline racist they do with a
black elf who ever heard of a negro else
let's not let him join in any elf hockey
right no if we did you probably couldn't
plate anyway that's one for us Santa not
me you cheer him previously then there
was the the island of misfit toys and
that special you remember say I would a
freak show that was this is basically an
island I hadn't watched this in years
where you go back and you see there
these toys that have like these minor
defects and Santa being the jolly old
Klansmen that he is Exiles them to an
island it's like it's this island
especially OSH fits for toys is what it
is and there was what there was the the
choo-choo with the square wheels
remember that there was the the squirt
gun that only shot jelly apparently that
was an unsolvable problem that's a user
here there was the oh there was the boat
that couldn't stay afloat yeah talking
about if you can't stay afloat you're a
shipwreck you have no business being a
but there was the Charlie in the box yes
I went that the chart you remember the
Charlie in the Box seemly
you snorted he's like hi do get my CPAP
get my CPAP the Charlie in a box if you
don't remember the island of misfit toys
the Charlie in the box was always
bitching about his name is oh no kid
wants to play with a Charlie in the box
okay first off if it's that much of a
problem for you Charlie
call yourself Jack dumbass I don't the
only way that these kids could know your
name is charlie is if you're telling
them long way around to say I don't like
rude or prompter I don't know why they
put anything on there I don't go with
anyways my fly unzips no okay good
after the bowtie Fiasco I thought
something was horribly wrong promo code
is credit Christmas by ten dollars often
known to locals as miss basket here's
the thing Christmas used to be kind of
one of those times that's by design
where everyone used to come together and
put aside our differences right like I
do feel as though we are living in a
time of more political division than
ever before and we used to be able to
reach across the aisle during Christmas
and now we have so little common ground
that it's all most important agree on
anything any what I'm just talking about
politics right you can avoid politics at
every single function you can avoid
politics at Thanksgiving it avoided
Christmas socio-economic issues
geopolitics but you can trigger someone
with anything that you say nowadays we
don't even have the fundamental
groundwork upon which we agree someone
can get pissed if you somehow imply that
the earth is a globe come on I come over
tonight Buffalo gals won't you come out
tonight and dance by the live of them
say marina what do you wish for when you
threw that raw no Mary you can tell me
no if I told you it wouldn't come true
come on Mary what what do you want do
you want the moon just just say the
words no throw lasso around pull it
right down I don't believe in the moves
very that's not a bad idea you swallow
it you don't believe in the moon no well
what on earth are you talking about it's
right there it's obvious you can tell
just by looking at it it's a
two-dimensional object well I bet you
think the earth is a globe no wait a
minute wait just a minute Mary hold hold
on with a two dimensional Oh Mary we
sent a man up there on that moon he went
up and climb through outer space oh you
don't really believe that crap do you
but don't don't believe what what gods
bring out for my hair and Mary I think
you hit your head in the bushes over
there that's the moon oh look at all the
photos they show us where are the stars
shadows right no you listen here Mary
Old Glory is flying high up on that moon
oh no that's the biggest lie of all if
we had really planted that flag on the
moon it wouldn't be flapping in the wind
what cuz there'd be no wind well that's
because they designed a special flag for
the photo Mary it has a parallel beam
perpendicular to the moon surface
otherwise a flag would just be just be
hanging there and you don't see the
stars because of the camera exposure
cameras what cameras George did you see
camera reflecting off of Neil
Armstrong's helmet when he took the
selfie button holy hell Zulfi everything
was staged to make America think we beat
the Russians one giant leap for mankind
by behind Hey what are you waiting for
won't you tell that brother third law of
thermodynamics you should you should
tell that broad the third law of
thermodynamics it's a good point mm-hmm
special thanks to the wonderful co-star
quarterblack Garrett's bald cap that was
there actually cheering for a bald cap
yeah I appreciate you know what you look
more like Keanu Reeves in this light
than I remember yeah okay all right we
get it okay okay all right well I'll be
sure to put a stop on that check there's
really no one who celebrates Hanukkah
here are we sure no one who can put a
stop and do is accounting for me if we
need someone who's a little bit clever
with numbers which by the way I don't
know if you know this I work for
according to the flat earth again oh yes
work for the accountants so listen I do
want to take this up see we're gonna
talk a little bit about Christmas about
how many people who celebrate Christmas
here in the United States and we're
gonna talk a little bit about other
holidays Kwanzaa why it's not really a
holiday at all it's fake I don't believe
in it not a real thing you won't
apologize for it but in the interim I
would like you to please welcome because
I have them on retainer and you don't
have a whole lot to do this year because
well this week anyway Google take some
time off near the holidays my half-asian
lawyer with a little medley here as an
homage to I believe Santa Baby about
Elizabeth Warren ladies and gentlemen my
half-asian lawyer bill Richman everybody
please keep it going for bill Richman so
we've got a wonderful guy here on the
Left mr. Gibbon give him a round of
applause he'll be helping us out with a
little tune here for our favorite
front-running lady for the Democratic
primary
this one is Warren baby
or and maybe slip some healthcare under
the tree it's free who pays who cares
it's not me
war and baby let's cuddle in your tepee
tonight
[Music]
[Music]
war and baby the rubes are reading up
your New Deal bright green tax the
taxpayers do war and baby let's snuggle
in your teepee tonight
think of all the interest missed
forgiving deaths of all those college
kids the polls next year will be oh so
good
if taxpayers fund my welfare lists
foreign baby open borders really that's
not a lot they're all angels down there
war and baby
let's go to an RTP tonight
[Music]
bill Richman ladies and gentlemen and
given of course given keep it going
forgiven you know I thought he was going
to play the violin no he plays about
know he played what are you what are you
what's wrong with you he does play the
violin not all Asians play the violin
just him and Ben Shapiro yeah I I mean
let him know you love him he had to
suffer horrible views from his Tiger mom
to pull that off guys apparently they
don't care that a small half asian child
had piano keys rammed into his net yeah
it doesn't mean anything to them that's
a true story ask him about it okay all
right let me see cuz I can't see
everybody here sorry I know some of you
in the back might not be able to see by
the way thank you for your service I can
see the one gentleman there and I can't
see who's next to him thank you very
much we appreciate it
we're glad that you're home now how many
are said you guys celebrate Christmas
yep okay there you go oh okay if ever I
ask anything I'll just need you guys to
either clap or say something because I
can't see all the hands I can see you
Thomas I appreciate it thank you very
much just don't look me in the eye he
creeps me out I don't a little bit I
appreciate it but I also a little bit
scared here's the thing you guys have
heard about the war on Christmas and you
have people on the left and on the right
who play into this I want you to know
it's it's not a thing meaning there is
no real war on Christmas at large I
should say there are very few select
people who are upset about Christmas who
want us to believe that there are people
who are offended at the idea of Merry
Christmas and then of course it sort of
ties in to feeds into outraged culture
where you have a lot of people on the
right who believe it as well
let me tell you something we just show
you some numbers really quickly before
we get to some I think we have to change
my mind segment that we did on Christmas
we're gonna get to Christmas is by far
by far the most favorite holiday of
Americans no other winter holidays even
croc crack crock Kruk well that's
Kwanzaa we'll get to that in a second
just we don't even cracked the top ten
okay 90% when we talk about the war on
Christmas and Happy Holidays vs. Merry
Christmas you would think well maybe
half the countries in celebrators know
90% of Americans celebrate Christmas by
the way and 46% of them don't even
celebrate it religiously it's important
to note that this surprise made 87% of
non-christians in this country
celebrate Christmas at 76 percent of
Asian Buddhists at 73 percent of Hindus
and 1/3 of Jews in the United States put
up Christmas trees right think about
think about that for say 90% of
Americans can we get 90% of Americans to
agree on anything else everything you
know genuinely a challenge outside of
like puppies can anyone think of 90% of
Americans getting along and agreeing on
anything else all right you can get back
to me I was waiting to see through
because there's nothing else absolutely
nothing else ninety percent and here's
something else when we talk about the
greeting this is important because you
see it a lot you know people get
outraged about Starbucks and I know
about you but like I couldn't care less
if they had a reindeer on a cup and then
I was only red and then you know you get
someone who's pissed off whether it's on
Fox News or MSNBC hairs when I asked
which greeting they prefer 52% of
Americans so that it doesn't matter at
all next high single is 32% of Americans
said that Merry Christmas was their
favorite only 15 percent preferred happy
holidays that means that of the
remaining 10% who don't celebrate
Christmas the vast majority of them are
not at all offended by the idea of
wishing somebody a Merry Christmas but
if you two if you were to watch this and
I see this a lot because we have a lot
of viewers who are either from Germany
or Japan or for some reason Brazil I
don't know why I don't know what they do
down there is some jiu-jitsu they make a
lot of knives that's great I don't know
what the contribution is but good on you
guys we have a lot of international
people who watch the show and they say
you know if I were to watch American
cable cable news I would think that you
have to hate Donald Trump in that
country that everybody despises him and
I would think that Christmas there's
some kind of a civil war going on over
Christmas so that's not the case there
is such a disconnect between what
actually happens with us and our
everyday life and what the media covers
and that's why I actually we sat down to
do it change my mind
on Christmas but there really was the
truth is we could
do a full change my mind segment because
most people didn't care so we had to cut
it down for you and the people who did
have opinions on it who came up to argue
I will say they had rather tepid
room-temperature opinions so Merry
Christmas changed my mind
Merry Christmas everybody change my mind
even though the majority of us like do
some celebrate Christmas they're still
Hanukkah there's some people that don't
celebrate either
sure how does me wishing you a Merry
Christmas prevent you from celebrating
let's say Hanukkah it's because so do
you think that corporations having
statements like happy holidays would be
more inclusive versus using Merry
Christmas I don't care Starbucks can do
whatever they want I don't shop at
Starbucks by the way I don't Lex didn't
say Merry Christmas they removed a
reindeer and made it a red cup I tell
you what I wasn't outraged at all this
is not about the [ __ ] on Christmas if
Starbucks wants to take off Christmas
and put up little red cups to the
heart's content and serve their crappy
overly burnt coffee I think it's just
unfair to continue that tradition of
working people with something which
might have sentiment which can be very
sensitive to other people
partners in that but 90% of Americans
celebrate Christmas religious or
non-religious a huge percentage
forty-seven percent of Americans who
celebrate Christmas don't even celebrate
it religiously a vast majority of the
remaining 10% receive it as positive but
for some reason its controversial no one
really cares so because 90% of Americans
celebrate Christmas I say Merry
Christmas if I knew you were Jewish
but have you ever met someone who
incidentally doesn't celebrate Christmas
you wish to Merry Christmas and it's
been offended no neither have I I have a
problem with a very very small but vocal
minority of people getting offended at
something that is not intended to be
offensive and exerting pressure I say
Merry Christmas
if someone's offended by it this is you
know pretty basic I don't like it I
think we both agree Merry Christmas is
in no way meant to be offensive
it's annoying affront if someone's
offended they can choose to be it
doesn't mean that I'm trying to be
offensive so I don't care what
corporations do I don't care what other
people say I just will say Merry
Christmas Christmas has done me good
will do me good and I say God bless it
and Merry Christmas to you that's all
I'm saying
[Music]
and here's the thing too we didn't plan
on doing this we did this a long time
ago Kwanzaa isn't real changed my mind
we did it at was it - at SMU I think so
you see you I don't they all blended
together you have one of those letters
yeah you know riddled with scandal I
assume as all universities are so we did
this a long time ago Kwanzaa isn't real
change my mind but we were not set up
for it we were not preparing on
discussing that on discussing this this
topic in Austin what this merry
christmas' changed my mind but I did
mention offhandedly and I'll get into
some more information after this next
video as to why it's not a real holiday
you don't you apologize for saying that
and some people got really upset right
let me just say this this is going to
sound terrible as opposed to everything
else you for tonight and the thing is
I've noticed that people get really
offended are almost always white people
yes and overweight angry women I'm sorry
I don't for the overweight angry women
out there it is not all overweight angry
women what a good job just some so and
we were talking of and I mentioned
offhandedly the Kwanzaa wasn't real as
we're switching the gear up on the
tables so I want you to understand this
context this is why the camera work is
weird we weren't planning on talking
about this but some people of course
immediately decided to take up arms for
Kwanzaa but as you'll see they weren't
exactly sure why this is about the
Kwanzaa comment yes it's not real yeah
it's a made-up holiday by a racist in
the 1960s
No hey did you celebrate Kwanzaa
no no african-american students you know
that it's less than 2% it notes we got
mad that I said Kwanzaa is not a real
holiday it's not it's not a real holiday
it's a fake holiday it's not a real
holiday in Africa and it was invented by
an abusive sexual harassing racist in
1966 named Ron Everett who called
himself Karenga he stuffed cot curling
irons in women's mouths and hoses with
cleaning solution and is based on
neo-marxist Black Liberation Theology
it's a fake racist holiday that no one
celebrates their art Oh
that's why no African Americans
celebrated I haven't met a single person
who celebrates it you do okay I would
love to hear you talk about Ron Everett
if you don't know who Ron ever it is my
guess is you probably not a huge Kwanzaa
fan
no but if he wants to talk about it I'll
tell you why they're legitimate and
kwanzas fake that's not where I'm going
okay you're wrong
do you tell the Christmas - okay merry
Christmas to you and I would say happy
Kwanzaa but it's not real I just I just
thought about if those people saw the
frosty clip that we played earlier yeah
we would have been run out of riff
here's here's what is absolutely
remarkable to me is um she said she
celebrated Kwanzaa didn't know who the
founder was and couldn't later on
couldn't name the date why do you care
about Kwanzaa so much and the
presumption right it's well it's not
legitimate because it's because white
people celebrate Christmas in Hanukkah
no okay how about this Christmas and
Hanukkah are legitimate because more
black people celebrated in Kwanzaa how
about that there are more black Jews and
there are African Americans who
celebrate Kwanzaa a lot of people don't
necessarily believe this when they hear
it less than 1% of Americans celebrate
Kwanzaa ok only 1 to 5 percent of
African Americans celebrate Kwanzaa
we're giving you the the most liberal
numbers we can the number is likely
closer to 1 percent total and I could
see some people were a little bit
confused let me kind of give you a brief
or on Kwanzaa because you know Google
and I think eBay had happy Kwanzaa up
there and I'm horribly ashamed I don't
know if you know this when I was a kid
there was a show I did called Martha
great Thank You Thomas was really
excited no give me more don't cheer
because I did that I played the brain on
Arthur which was a little smart
character who was a parent here's what I
didn't know until the Christmas special
they handed me my song on the album
yeah and I realize it was a Kwanzaa song
and my character was black hey that's
not even your focus on your vice noses
true the brain was a black bear I had no
idea
first off lots of drugs involved with
this idea it's a pet it's an aardvark
who has a pet dog and a best friend
who's a rabbit and a black bear no one's
getting mauled fine okay we'll go with
it along with the son that lives under a
sea with a minor gay roommate I think
they were just experimenting the point
remains so then they said you have to
sing about Kwanzaa and I did this and
this was a this was a rude awakening
true story as a kid I was so bad at
doing a Christmas song on the arthurs
perfect Christmas special and I think
this was God's Way of saying I'm gonna
teach you about Kwanzaa later because I
didn't know at the time that they
recorded over all my vocals with
background singers so I went in I
recorded for seven hours that they was
twelve years old
and unceremoniously I was fired I went
and listened okay I think I really got
that track and I had a bunch of rap
because Kwanzaa black bear that's true
was a Kwanzaa rap and I pop in Arthur's
perfect Christmas the CD to hear three
minutes of people I've never heard in my
life go ahead come together now it's
Kwanzaa time that's it that's the whole
song yeah and then I was fired six
months later because I didn't know
anything about Kwanzaa beckon so let me
give you a little bit of a briefer on
Kwanzaa it was made up in 1966 by a
black nationalist his name was Ron Evert
okay he now goes by the name Maulana
Karenga because Ron's typically do yes
you know and lest you think I'm making
this up he was actually convicted of
kidnapping and torturing two women who
by the way were members of his black
nationalist organization I want to make
sure I get this right so I'm reading it
here he stripped the naked whipped them
with an electrical cord beat them with
batons put detergent and running hoses
in their mouths put their toes and vices
and forced hot soldiering irons against
their faces and their mouths this is the
founder of the feast of Kwanzaa a lot of
people don't know that we act as that we
put on this legitimate pedestal as
Christmas and Hanukkah and holidays that
have obviously I don't know what
about about Hanukkah but certainly
Passover and Christmas a deeply rich
historical cultural religious undertones
and we somehow throw Kwanzaa in as
though it should be in the same lot and
it absolutely shouldn't and just to see
how many people who apparently celebrate
Kwanzaa know all of this about Kwanzaa
or how passionate they really are we
actually there was what was it called
quarter black garrett Kwanzaa fest
Kwanzaa fest we now you would think
Kwanzaa fest that would be ground zero
for Kwanzaa yes yes no one person is she
the one percent would be there different
one percent here sad one percent and I
was and then quarter black Garrett came
back with this package I was very
confused so this was Kwanzaa fest and
what's the name of the guy he was
putting it on at john wiley price do you
guys know john wiley price from here in
dallas an elected official so he's a
representative of you guys here in
dallas texas he was putting on Kwanzaa
fest in dallas texas quarter black
garrett our african-american black
quarter black correspondent went down to
Kwanzaa fest to see how much they know
about Kwanzaa Thank You Garrett enjoy
the van
all right we're here with John Wiley
price the founder of the feast here the
Kwanzaa Fest do you celebrate Kwanzaa
since it is a made-up holiday like is
their roots back in Africa they're like
some kind of holiday that might go with
it
well right ever it made it up in Africa
did they celebrate like a specific
holiday specifically African American
Mina made up just for
Kwanza quiz I got7 Kwanzaa questions for
you representing the seven pillars of
Kwanzaa you don't know what Kwanzaa is
are you guys from around here
what does the term Kwanzaa mean in
Swahili
one of the Seven Pillars of Kwanzaa
I saw those I can never remember unity
self-determination connect the words of
economic purpose
what is the percentage of the
african-american community that
celebrates Kwanzaa sixty-three percent
forty to fifty percent
one person
all right these last few questions are
about the founder of Kwanzaa
so I bet you know all this a lot of the
cooking you know you got all this what
was his original birth name
I should know that but I
sounds like a white guy's name his birth
name was Ron Everett
Ronald everything number five Ron
Everett Karenga stood trial and was
sentenced in which year
and you he was a black nationalist
that is true he was for which crimes was
run every Church bank robber that's a
good that's a good guess I think it's
off the cuff wrong physical violence
sexual violence and torture she knows
everything about boys you think like
naturalism is bad
according to the testimony how did run
Everett sexually assault two of his
female followers
I may be hitting this multiple things
that happened on kidnapped
four-dimensional
all right I'll give you tortured you get
it got tortured I'm gonna tell you what
he did he stripped him down naked
whipped him with electrical cord beat
him with karate batons put their toes
and vices pour detergent and running
hoses in their mouths and burn their
face in their mouth with hot soldering
iron
I know that's what I'm saying I don't
know we knew that to be back don't know
anything about that
and what we celebrate
so much quarterblack carrot I appreciate
it no problem anytime anytime that seems
like a horrible waste of time and budget
but unless you went out there all right
listen we will actually have after this
break a word from our sponsors we're
gonna have Santa Claus here live in
studio with some gifts for all of you in
the audience Santa Claus will be here
stay tuned the word from our sponsors
[Applause]
[Music]
did you have a good Christmas yeah
pretty good get everything you wanted
almost almost time well that's life yes
there's always next Christmas yep say
that's funny what's that over there
we're behind the desk over there go take
a look
oh wow
why would Ana Walther PPQ 9 millimeter
or the 42 5.6
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just say the word throw a lasso around
oh yeah I don't believe in the moon say
that's a good idea
you could swallow
deepen your goal why did I say the
plaintiff no longer gonna be able to
show my face in court okay good deal
this chick makes be invested guitar solo
there's frenemies trendy
[Music]
that day let me show you boys out really
doesn't matter with Crowder shopkins
supporting free speech since 2000 and
something with people being banned from
social media left and right you can now
purchase this D platform this limited
edition louder with better shop.com
t-shirt
signifying your in subordinates to
authority and request for them to kiss
your ass and lick your bladder with
Photoshop calm today
[Music]
ja your Christmas morning like a patriot
go to black rifle coffee calm slash
Crowder today what's your home defense
plan when it comes to safety there's no
substitute for a quality firearm and if
you're a gun owner there's no
replacement for firearms legal
protection firearms legal protection
provides lawful gun owners an uncapped
legal defense program 24/7 emergency
hotline access to a network of over
2,500 experienced attorneys legal
education on firearm laws in your state
be our mobile app and plans to protect
you every step of the way if you are
involved in a self-defense ensign visit
firearms legal comm /lw see today we are
back further down the stream we have
people live here two hundred people in
Dallas Texas
technically Las Colinas Las Colinas yeah
this is Las Colinas right think I
believe it is which I managed for find a
white person I dare you
I think I'm not entirely sure on the
nomenclature thank you so much to our
wonderful sponsors by the way for the
whole year this is the only reason we're
able to do this show I can't think
Walter black rifle coffee FLP enough
we've been demonetised as you know on
YouTube they've made this happen for
those who are tuning in promo code is
Crowder Christmas you get $10 off
through Christmas if you join my club
$10 goes to local Christmas baskets for
Christmas charity we appreciate it all
right now is the moment that you've all
been waiting for you may know him as
Kris Kringle Saint Nicholas blob of
fauna but he's here to give some gifts
to people in the crowd and spread some
Christmas cheer late and gentlemen Santa
Claus
[Applause]
yeah how are you doing Oh doing
wonderful Steven how are you okay a
little loud and your elf seems to be
carrying your weight quite a bit since
Santa what what are you what do you plan
on doing here tonight for the wonderful
people in the audience I have some
lovely gifts for these boys and girls oh
really oh man give them out no well
there are no boys and girls with two
pies here pretty okay think he's gonna
give them anyway okay so so cancel for
people what's your name all right did
you ask Santa for anything for Christmas
this year good a plastic flask himself
were you a good boy this year not get
something else there's another boy flies
when he's a full beer to enquire there
you go National Enquirer hello Thomas I
remember you would you like some of
these no no oh okay
luckily I have something else in here
okay kids just a moment you're gonna
follow me out onto the stage but first I
want to know who's ready to meet Santa
Claus there are samples I can't Santa
Santa Claus it seems seems like you may
just be giving out some stuff that you
found in your house well how else are
they supposed to finish their houses
Steven I didn't understand what you said
because of your drunken
but I assume that it's okay Oh what else
do I have is that a pie crust are you
allergic to peanuts all right say Anna
she's wearing a nice dress keep your
hands where we can see them okay I'm
doing my best
all right well it's you're not very good
would you like some utensils were you
good I don't know what acid trip you are
an ass would you like some roast wait
does that remem cut does that meet its
pre few very roof it's rough that's me
it's not rain dude that is that is that
is mom Santa okay you know that's a
that's a terrible safety hazard and we
don't have a license but Santa why don't
you come over it's Santa come on over
here yeah we got enough with the gifts
you guys by the way please return home
after the show they have not been
inspected Santa yes okay this is never
gone very well yeah once you have a seat
and thank goodness I think they heard it
from my microphone says I don't think
let's not do the gifts anymore I think I
have one more Steven have you been a
good boy
unlike the audience I can answer with an
emphatic yes Steven I'm gonna give you
the deed to my slave what because I want
you to be the next Senate Clause wait
wait wait this is a form acknowledging
that you're a registered sex offender
all right yeah that was just
we will not be invited back to the blaze
all right
I think I yeah okay go chair I think
it's a method acting yeah that was all
that without a bottle of Chardonnay that
thing is half empty I thought I smelled
that backstage oh that's horrible
someone's getting fired all right well
listen it's getting pretty close to
closing out the show this evening and I
know I apologize what we spending some
more time with you afterward but you
know I want to say that tonight we
actually we were going to have my
mother-in-law here who toured with
Aretha Franklin and Joni Mitchell and
she's actually very sick so prayers
appreciated for my mother-in-law right
now but one thing I do want to bring
your attention there's so many people
here on this team who work behind the
scenes and not just like the sponsors
that we've spoken about and of course
all of you who join up at Mudd Club but
this wouldn't be possible and I wanted
to showcase for you actually someone
who's newer to the show but we've all
been pretty amazed by his talent great
um a lot of the musical parodies that
we've been doing this year and a lot of
people's well you never used to do those
that's because they weren't possible
until some new additions to the team so
I would like you to welcome someone who
often blows me away and makes me very
angry because of the natural unbridled
talent which I did not have our very own
singing oh holy night audio wait ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
Oh Holy Night the stars are brightly
shining it is the night of our dear
saviors birth only the world in sin and
error pining till he appeared and the
soul felt it's worth a thrill of hope
the weary world rejoices for yonder
brings a new and glorious morn fly
on your knees whoo-hee
angel voices or not
give
when Christ was born
[Music]
whoa
I give why
all night all night Eva
[Music]
- he taught us to uh neither his law is
love and his gospel is peace chains
shall he break for the slave is a bra
and in his name all oppression shall
cease sweet hymns of joy in grateful
chorus raise we for young
a new and glorious morn fall on your
knee woohee
angel
Oasis will not
Angela
I know when Christ was born worn ah jeez
I know night holy night
[Music]
[Applause]
I appreciate this year it's been a great
year we'll be back the second week of
January and before I finish this out I
also want to give credit and thanks to
everyone who works on this team please
let them hear that you love them
quarterblack Eric - cute Maddy
he brought it in Pantelis given Bryce
Brendan Garin a good one are missing
they would Tim from HR or even that guy
[Applause]
getting anyone leave thank you guys so
much
everyone have a Merry Christmas a Happy
New Year and not Kwanzaa because it's
not a real thing thank you so much god
bless everybody
[Applause]